as you may or may not be aware i
recently purchased not one
but two of these brand new m1 ipad pros
and today i wanted to test out the lidar
capabilities of it
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about the lines our
capabilities of an
m1 ipad pro and how functional it is and
how useful it is for somebody like
myself who's a practicing architect here
in western australia so for lidar to be
really useful
you want it to be accurate accuracy is
one of the most important things to me
as an architect
when it comes to lidar scanning now
obviously i'm aware that this m1 ipad
pro
won't be 100 perfect it won't be 100
accurate with the lidar we probably
don't need that case so pop that over
there
the lidar on the back of here should be
relatively close
so i've got my measuring tape out i've
got my ipad and i'm ready to do a couple
scans
now full disclosure i've gone ahead and
downloaded a whole bunch of apps
to see which ones are good and which
ones will and won't make the cut
i've trimmed it down to three apps in
particular that we're going to be
testing out today so the three apps that
we're talking about today is magic plan
polycam and scaniverse okay so magic
plan
is a relatively simple floor plan
utensil
basically the purpose of it is to go
around and measure the room
and be able to quickly and easily tap on
any object
so that you're able to add a door for
example or a window
and it automatically recognizes what
it's looking at i scanned this room as a
trial to see
what it would come out as and it
actually did a pretty good job
now unfortunately the overall
measurements weren't 100 accurate they
were actually quite far off out of all
three apps
magic plan was the least accurate now i
don't know if that specifically because
it isn't a lidar specific app
it's more so an architectural program
than anything else that it missed things
but it tried to analyze corners for
example
and because this table hides the corner
it really struggled to find that corner
if you're scanning a completely empty
house this app would be 100 perfect and
you wouldn't have to go ahead and take
your tape measure with you
to measure every single wall even the
doors and the windows it didn't really
accurately pick up so for example the
window to my left is approximately 1.45
meters wide
and it picked it up as only 1.38 so
overall it's not completely inaccurate
but you're still better off
using either a measuring tape or a laser
scanner like you usually would
nonetheless you can get a pretty good
floor plan out of it
if you're doing something like real
estate floor plans and you just want to
quickly run around
and capture everything as quickly as
possible this is actually really really
good i don't think i'd be able to
produce something on the computer
quicker than i can do it with this just
going out wall
wall door door so i think for
more so of a marketing plan than an
actual architectural plan or just
something that you want to quickly
reference back to
this is a great backup app but i still
wouldn't use it as
something to take over the physical
measurements that you'd have to do on
site unlike the other apps magic plan
does work in portrait and landscape mode
both of the other two apps i'm about to
discuss
are fixed to portrait mode unfortunately
so you can't turn your ipad sideways and
scan the property the more natural way i
guess you have to run around
this way it just seems a little odd to
me but
maybe they'll fix that in an update
later on whereas magic plan does allow
you to switch and change as you like
unfortunately magic plan only produces a
2d floor plan at the end of the day
it doesn't give you a full lighter 3d
fly through
like the other two apps do but it does
produce a very good floor plan that you
can actually go ahead
and import into something like archicad
if you wanted to
moving on to polycam polycam is a
fantastic
lidar scanner and i'm actually tossing
and turning if it's my favorite
out of all three of these apps that i'm
reviewing today polycam
is phenomenal so basically it's just
like magic floor plan
you run around you scan the environment
and
it does the lidar scanning for you so
overall
the end result of a full room scan isn't
a hundred percent clear you still have
to make out what the objects are
what's going on in the environment but
overall the measurements are pretty
close
unlike magic floor plan it's able to
pick up when a desk is covering a corner
because it's not looking for those
corner nodes to actually create a floor
plan
it's able to actually interpret the
environment as best as possible
and to be honest if i spent a lot more
time actually scanning the environment
taking it slowly
understanding every single dot point it
probably could create something a lot
better than the quick
rushed 3d scan i produced one of the
best things about polycam for me
is the simple fact that the ruler tool
is highly effective and highly accurate
so unlike magic plan where it wasn't
able to pick up corners
this one you're able to measure whatever
you need pretty quickly
it's not 100 accurate still but it is a
lot closer
so for example this room back to front
is about 3.2 meters
whereas it's only picked up 3.05
so there still is a pretty big
discrepancy but if you're going
again as a backup plan to your physical
measurements on site this is actually
phenomenal
now the best thing about polycam which
is better than any other program that
we're discussing today
is the simple floor plan feature now
just like magic plan created that floor
plan
it does give you a full 3d floor plan
view it automatically dimensions
all the corners of the room so for
example if you had a complex
room with lots of corners lots of
truncations it can quickly pick that up
for you
it doesn't produce a highly detailed
floor plan
like magic plan does it's not something
you could export or give to somebody or
use
a marketing plan it's literally just
there as
an addition to that lidar scan that it's
created as well as giving you those
overall dimensions of wall lengths it
gives you
areas of walls as well so if you were
doing a lidar scan of a large wall
you could quickly calculate the area on
site know exactly how much wall mass you
need to cover
if you're trying to build somebody for
something per square meter it's again a
fantastic tool
to just quickly get something together i
know i'm definitely carrying around my
ipad all the time
i'm not really carrying around a
measuring tape or a laser scanner
ever so if i need something quickly on
site this is
definitely the go-to the overall 3d scan
as well
is pretty good it isn't a hundred
percent detailed
if i was to look around this room for
example that i've modeled
it gets all the majority in there so
it'll pick up
the memorabilia on the wall it'll pick
up the frames behind me it'll pick up
the computer the desk
the computer underneath it'll pick up
the general shape of the chairs
it's not something that you'd be able to
go into and actually
model for example like the mouse and
import it into a rendering program
unfortunately none of the apps i've
tried and tested to date on the m1 ipad
pro
have that capability to truly grasp
small objects
to be able to be used and implemented
into a rendering program
so that's definitely something i'm
looking forward to and exploring more
because there's a lot of real world
objects i'd love to be able to produce
and put into software
but for now i still haven't figured it
out 100 just like magicam you can export
this
raw data to whatever you want so for
example if i wanted to export this as a
point cloud or as an
obj that i could then import into
archicad or twin motion
i definitely could i don't know how much
data i'd actually preserve or how much
data i'd need to preserve
this would be more so the model required
just directly
on this software and on the ipad once
again with polycam i don't think it is
the primary source of
data that you should be taking on site i
definitely still think you need to take
measurements by hand or with a laser
scanner and not rely entirely on the
lidar in the m1 ipad pro
moving on to scaniverse scaniverse is
very similar to polycam
it produces a 3d lidar object
of the room that you've scanned and it
does a phenomenal job
comparing it directly to polycam in
quality only
it produces significantly better
lidar results now you may not think this
as you're using the app and using the
scanner scanning around the room
i know personally i didn't i thought it
was going to be a much worse quality
render
but at the end of the day it produced
much better shapes much cleaner edges
and i was able to interpret the data a
lot better as a result of having
much cleaner edges and a much better
lidar scan
it therefore also produces significantly
better
measurements so like i said overall
length of this room 3.2 it picked it up
as
3.15 so very very
marginally off the window to my left 1.5
like i previously mentioned
1.48 on this app and on this
lidar scan now each one of those
measurements is obviously not 100
correct
but i would be comfortable going back at
this 3d scan
and going i missed that measurement what
was it
it was it 70 was it 80 mil was it 800
was it a meter i could then take an
informed
guess at what it should be so for
example the door i could measure the
door and go
okay that's an 820 door or a 920 door
so just by experience and the use of
this app i think you could get
some seriously good information by using
all of this point cloud data
unfortunately unlike magic plan and
unlike polycam
it doesn't have a top view 3d floor plan
that gives you automatic measurements
for the time being
all we have is simple touch and drag
measurements
so if you want a measurement of
something particular you have to
actually go out
and measure it on the screen itself it
doesn't give you
that bird's eye view that's really
really helpful something that it does
have over the other two
is potentially in my personal opinion a
bit more gimmicky
it's not really required you're never
really going to use it i don't know
why anybody would but that is moving
into the future scandiverse
does have ar and object features
directly built in to the lidar scan
so if i wanted to produce an ar
version of my scan somewhere on site
bring it up walk through with my ipad
and experience it like i was there again
i could i can't do that on any of the
other two apps
it's not overly useful to me as an
architect i don't think it's overly
useful
to anybody it's gimmicky like i said but
it's something pretty cool
it means we can actually bring it up to
scale walk through it
and get all those details we're looking
for if i could only pick one
i wouldn't to be honest with you because
all three of them have
different features and different
functionalities magic plan is
phenomenal at taking those floor plans
and just creating floor plans very very
quickly
i'm sure i could go around my whole
house and just create a marketing floor
plan
and potentially even sell that to real
estate agent for a couple hundred bucks
so if that's something that you're
looking to do as a side business as a
hustle
perfect app and it is phenomenally
reliable however if you're looking for
an actual point cloud
lidar scan that doesn't give you that
through the app
just yet polycam gives you some
phenomenal features
it is very quick very easy to use very
intuitive
and it does give you overall dimensions
and areas that you might be looking for
unfortunately scaniverse is
significantly better in the point cloud
and lighter
information that it produces and exports
but it doesn't have
those features of the overall bird's eye
view dimensions and areas
so it really does depend what you're
looking for personally i think i'll
probably be using scaniverse on-site a
lot more than anything else
if i need to i might use magic floor
plan
and to be 100 honest with you i'll most
likely delete
polycam anyway that's all for me today
guys thank you so much for watching i
hope you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below and don't
forget about the like button
the like button helps this video with
the youtube algorithm helps this channel
grow tremendously
as it has been over the past couple
months so thank you so much for being a
member of this community
there's a couple links down below as
well if you want to join our discord
community
where we talk about architecture we
share our experiences and we just talk
about projects in general
also every single tutorial i do is
linked in the discord chat
so you can download all my pln files for
archicad tutorials and all my twin
motion files as well
potentially i might start doing some
photoshop tutorials all of that
will be in the legend level discord chat
so if that's something you want to check
out
the links are down below but like i said
that's all for me today so i will see
you
next monday